lawmakers considering whether there
should be licensing and oversight for
midwives and home births in the state of
nevada as the i-team first reported last
week
only one type of midwife is regulated
those are certified nurse midwives
because registered nurses are licensed
by the state however
there is no oversight of traditional
midwives and certified professional
midwives
many of them do not have medical
training assembly bill
387 would create that oversight
opponents say any regulation would take
away a woman's choice
about where she can give birth and who
can care for her
both sides voiced their opinions this
evening
so that's the premise for ab387
licensure is a key to providing safe
care for nevadans
that is consistent with the scope of
practice defined by the profession
it also makes midwifery more accessible
and enables them to participate in an
integrated system that includes
opportunities for consultation
collaboration
referral and multi-disciplinary peer
review
we cannot support a bill that will
decrease the middle free labor workforce
in nevada
negatively impact future workforce
development detract from nevada's
historical support of apprenticeship
trades
negatively impact primarily women-owned
businesses have negative financial
impacts on the economy and cause the
domino effect of restricting the choices
of women and birthing people in nevada
there is also a senate bill under
consideration you can check out the
i-team's full reports on midwifery at
eight
newsnow dot com